un comunicado que contrasta Gabriel
boric se pronunció de manera categórica
en contra del despojo de la nacionalidad
de 94 nicaragüenses por parte del
régimen autocrático de Daniel Ortega un
abrazo fraterno a Gioconda Sergio Sofía
Carlos y a todos quienes Ortega ha
pretendido despojarlos de su
nacionalidad nicaragüense no sabe el
dictador que la patria se lleva en el
corazón y en los actos y no se priva por
decreto no están solos
el mensaje vista de los pronunciamientos
de los mandatarios de la región
latinoamericana que han sido mucho menos
terminantes según señaló Guillermo
holmesmann analista político para France
24 este responde un enfoque de Derechos
Humanos propio de borich que marca su
política exterior
eso lo lleva por ejemplo a plantear de
que Venezuela eso dio la cédula de hecho
humanos lo propio también en Nicaragua
por supuesto también en Cuba y
resalta de comunicados como el mucho más
Homero el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores expresa su preocupación por
la decisión de retirar también la
nacionalidad nicaragüense a otros 94
ciudadanos Brasil y Argentina por
ejemplo Siguen sin pronunciarse la
postura de la región está muy marcada
por visión ideológica y expectativas
ideologías que se han ofrecido la
población lo que hoy día ha hecho
Gabriel boriche colocar un punto de
inflexión y progresivo de América Latina
en términos de coherencia y política
particularmente y que deberá llevar
probablemente a un debate y si es que no
a un cambio de posición las medidas
tomadas por Ortega se enmarcan en una
nueva ley proclamada que regula la
pérdida de nacionalidad nicaragüense un
paso más hacia la persecución política a
la oposición en el país centroamerica